es ist kurz nach sechs am morgen bei
familie solingen hast du deine zähne
geputzt
nein nein immer noch nicht mustafas
element und seine frau wir machen die
vier kinder für kindergarten und schule
fertig ich habe das schon alleine
gemacht
okay okay alles gut vor fünf jahren sind
diese domains nach deutschland
geflüchtet vor dem krieg aus syrien mit
den beiden söhnen gut und karam und
tochter lara der jüngste sohn sam ist in
deutschland geboren
sie haben sich das leben hier einfacher
vorgestellt nach vier jahren und
unzähligen umzügen haben sie nun
erstmals ihre eigene wohnung langsam
verbessert sich unsere situation und wir
fühlen uns immer wohler aber ich kann
noch nicht sagen das ist meine neue
heimat ist ich gewöhne mich immer mehr
und das leben hier und ich verstehe das
land immer besser auf dem weg zur schule
in berlin spandau
gib mir deine hand sami wir müssen über
die straße
lama geht gerne in die schule schule und
kita ein fulltime job für moustafa und
api suleman
sie unterstützen ihre kinder rund um die
uhr damit die integration in die neue
sprache und kultur auch klappt das
kostet sie viel kraft nach allem was sie
erlebt haben
rückblick 2015 bereitet mustafa suleiman
seine kinder in der türkei auf die
flucht im schlauchboot über das
mittelmeer vor über die balkanroute
erreicht die familie nach wochen
deutschland festgehalten
in einer reportage der deutschen welle
die flucht und der krieg haben spuren
hinterlassen bis heute
mustafa suleman wurde bei einem
bombenangriff verwundert er durchlebt
seither todesängste muss regelmäßig in
therapie
nun sieht der kasseler schlimmer
sulemans mutter ist vor zwei wochen in
syrien gestorben
das ja nicht bei ihr sein konnte quält
und zerreißt ihn erzählt er
hier ist in den letzten wochen war sie
sehr krank und sie wurde dann ins
krankenhaus gebracht ich habe versucht
mit ihr zu sprechen
aber sie konnte nicht mehr sprechen und
sie hat mich auch nicht mehr
die bindung zu seiner familie ist sehr
eng der vater starb als muster für
sohnemann 14 jahre war als ältester hat
er früh verantwortung übernommen
die mutter zog neun kinder alleine groß
eine sehr starke frau sehr stark sie
haben sehr viele furchtbare dinge erlebt
viele schmerzen ertragen
aber ich denke dass jetzt wirklich
mitmachen wird in die zukunft gucken in
die zukunft schauen sich um die familie
mehrere kinder um sich selbst kümmern
aber auch wenn breuer denke das machen
sie wirklich gut und da können sie auch
stolz auf sich sein
so lange weil es noch schwer seinem
platz in deutschland zu finden
viele syrer die er hier kennt arbeiten
oder haben sich selbstständig gemacht so
vietnam
er leitet die filiale eines restaurants
es braucht zeit bis sich etwas
entwickelt aber gott sei dank unser
restaurant ist jetzt sehr bekannt und
hat einen guten ruf wenn du
irgendjemandem fragst sagen sie dir wo
das restaurant ist toll und es läuft
wohl
jaja das restaurant ist bekannt für das
gute essen und es ist sehr sauber und
als gast wirst du gut behandelt
mustafa suleman will bald auch anfangen
zu arbeiten
doch sein deutsch muss noch besser
werden das feld seinen kindern leichter
du siehst berlin schon zur heimat
geworden und wird ingenieur in berlin
werden aber sich auch um das haus der
familie in syrien kümmern macht eine
hand weg du liebst du mich nicht lieben
euch doch beide ich liebe euch alle
[Musik]